let me introduce at this time our two
senior speakers Morgan Delp is a senior
with a 3.5 5 grade point average her
major is history of a minor his
journalism Oregon intends to pursue a
career as a writer at Hillsdale she
belongs to the Catholic society and the
Kappa Kappa Gamma sorority she
volunteers for the king's covered
project and the Hillsdale buddy project
and serves on the student athletic
Advisory Committee she also helps with
the campus newspaper that's an
understatement she's the editor of the
campus newspaper this year she
participates in the journalism program
and plays on the women's tennis team to
cover to help cover her college expenses
she works as a student affairs mentor as
well I teased Morgan before the ceremony
that I was going to add that she also
takes classes Morgan is the oldest of
five children
her sister Sydney attends Hillsdale the
family resides in Holland Ohio and her
father is the chairman and chief
executive officer of the TBC thank you
dr. Whalen
good afternoon hell's Dell College class
of 2018 parents students faculty staff
and guests I am truly honored to be able
to speak to you all today it's hard to
believe that three years ago I sat where
you are sitting it's even harder to
believe that my sister Sydney is sitting
among you as a mentor and her third year
here and that my little brother Dugan is
sitting out there as a freshman a part
of me wants to use this time to
embarrass him in front of his future
classmates since he is so smart and
clever that it's usually him poking fun
at me but I will spare him that
humiliation and you all the family
stories when it was time to say goodbye
to my family like you will do soon I
turned to face my dad whose eyes were
welling up with tears I couldn't believe
my strong optimistic dad was crying at
my departure starting to become
emotional myself and preparing words of
encouragement in my head I embraced him
and a hug I expected some hurtful
heartfelt words from dear old dad
as his firstborn left home for the first
time but instead he said I wish I was
going to college while lacking
appropriate fatherly sentiment my dad at
Hillsdale graduate summed up in that act
how special and happy of a place
Hillsdale was for him while a lot of
things have changed around here since he
graduated in 1986 the happiness of its
students has not recently the
prestigious Princeton Review ranked
Hillsdale 10th and happiest students of
all colleges in the country the reason
it's the people seeing on is a sign seen
on a sign as you enter Hillsdale this
well-worn motto reflects the
friendliness and quirkiness of the
town's 8,000 or so citizens although it
has almost become a cliche around here
it's a fitting summation for the college
as well
we are all here because we believe in
higher things like beauty truth and
goodness even if you haven't learned
exactly how to express them yet we want
to become better thinkers better people
it is happy to be around others who
value these things at a certain level it
starts with a faculty and staff they
truly care about us students my
professors have had my classmates and me
to their homes for dinner multiple times
I've given tennis lessons to my
professors children people invite their
teachers to their weddings I have
attended a wedding of two students that
was held at a professor's house just the
other morning Steve Cassie who greets
everyone as they enter the North family
dining room made it a point to show me a
picture of myself playing tennis in one
of the recent Hillsdale mailings the
kindness of those that lead our school
trickles down to and throughout the rest
of campus homer in the odyssey a book
you freshmen will all read said for a
friend with an understanding heart is
worth no less than a brother homer is
right and you will make those family
like friends here at Hillsdale it's a
hard school an understanding will come
in handy from your roommate when in a
couple weeks you receive
your first ever see and cry on the phone
to your mom for an hour but that
understanding friend will also be there
to celebrate your first a which you
achieve only after hundreds of combined
library and office hours some of your
best memories will be staying up until
2:00 a.m. in the Suites little computer
room writing a Western religion essay
with four of your Hall mates or bonding
in the library with someone unexpected
while trying to understand the physics
of Isaac Newton for physical science
class you'll look back and remember the
van rides to the Upper Peninsula with
your tennis team the president's balls
with your sorority sisters the welcome
parties with friends the late nights in
the collegian office with your fellow
editors at least these are the things I
know I will remember there's something
more than just our shared age group and
approximate location that drew us into
these friendships with one another
it's that truth that our real school
motto tells us we pursue as expressed in
our honor code every other student here
has signed and agreed to this code like
you have sure we will fail to live up to
that at times but we attend to school
where others hold you accountable for
your actions being honorable dutiful and
respectful as that code states is
important the best examples of this Duty
and the kindness of the people on this
campus can be summed up in two
embarrassing experiences I had my
freshman year which may serve to ease
your nerves the first time you show up
late to class or trip walking up the
dorm stairs one evening while eating
dinner in the dining hall by myself I
made myself a bowl of the granola cereal
I devoured it but within minutes I could
feel my throat swelling I'm allergic to
one of the nuts in the mix and being the
fopen freshman I was didn't think to ask
any of the employees what the mix
contained I sprinted to the back office
where two students who saw me panicking
followed quickly behind the food staff
went to work on calling 9-1-1 and
getting me help one of the students a
close friend stayed with me to keep me
calm while the other a girl I barely
knew sprinted to my dorm room to
retrieve my epi
I lucked out because she was a
nationally ranked swimmer who was also
very fast on land I recovered quickly
after a trip to the ER where my friends
stayed with me the entire time you think
I would have learned my lesson at that
point but only weeks later I suffered a
similar reaction in a JS cafe this time
by the ice cream God was watching over
me again because as my throat started to
swell and I slunk down lower in my AJ's
booth two girls noticed my concern and
marched me to the bathroom this time I
had my EpiPen I will never forget how
the one let me squeeze her hand until it
turned blue as I injected myself with
the pen and how the other drove me to
the Hillsdale hospital and that year's
first snowstorm driving about 15 miles
per hour the entire way while I hope all
of you do not have to learn the
greatness of hills dales people in this
embarrassing and dangerous way I do hope
you do experience it what's more I hope
you become these people to others be the
people that seek the best in themselves
and others be the ones that uphold our
honor code via the people that think for
themselves practice individual
responsibilities and work hard if you
embrace the next four years and beyond
in such a way it may be you sitting out
there 25 years from now tearing up as
you say goodbye to your daughter on her
first day of college remembering them
people that made Hillsdale College so
special
you